Vikings could be connected to the far
right according to a police-backed audit
of monuments linked to what they call
oppressive Behavior I would say Vikings
are a bit Yeah oppressive this is
northumbria police they took part in a
review of statues and landmarks to
establish which sites might be
associated with slavery and other forms
of Oppression uh this is according to
documents seen by the Telegraph and the
audit decided that several sites related
to Vikings could have associations with
far-right symbolism I think the axes
does that have something to do with
far-right symbolism or something or or
is it the fact that they raped and
pillaged and did the rest of it easiest
and also they had gender critical views
and how did they the Vikings yes
they didn't they didn't understand you
know the whole trans Patron they didn't
announce their pronouns when they came
in to do a bit of raping it was all very
problematic you just can't have that so
Vikings they have to go don't they
Vikings have to yeah they have to go I
think that apparently
um uh Hitler who was apparently a Nazi
yes
um adopted some some Viking symbolism
and so we've attached connected the two
and that's not the Vikings fault no
they've been gone for a while exactly
and um I think that people uh wanted to
attack the statue itself if you've seen
it's quite ugly the statue it's modern
so you think it was aesthetic I think so
I think the locals were like we'd like
to take this down and put some flowers
so it's just an excuse ready to attack
them the problem is flowers can be
fascist you know they can they can
obviously yeah they've got one opinion
they've got one bud that's all you get
yep no that's fair enough I just think
when you're sort of trying to cancel
Vikings haven't you sort of you've
jumped the shark surely at that point I
think you jumped the shark a wall yeah I
think so I mean thank God for the
Vikings you're you're Irish yeah right
what the Vikings got to do with Ireland
because the Irish people look better
because the Vikings went there they're
pillaged and raped and made you know
they're a lovely seed well God before
that there's okay dwellings in people's
unibrows can you imagine English people
without Nordic bone structure seriously
I mean you've just sort of like
misshapen potatoes
putting an end to this right now because
we're teaching into xenophobia so just
leaning in very enthusiastically I
should say
thank you